[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Make it 2-nil, Chicago Fire.
[MUSIC - THE SCORE,
"UNSTOPPABLE (STRIPPED)"]
Fire scores!
[MUSIC - THE SCORE,
"UNSTOPPABLE (STRIPPED)"]
- Nikolic-- second goal today.
- Sensational stuff!
The rebound, Katai.
- Schweinsteiger from
distance-- yes, what a strike!
[MUSIC - THE SCORE,
"UNSTOPPABLE (STRIPPED)"]
- He does it again,
and the Fire lead.
- Schweinsteiger from
distance-- yes, what a strike.
- Played ahead by
Schweinsteiger,
touches around, and
Schweinsteiger crosses,
it's in.
- Back to Schweinsteiger,
fires, scores.
Bastian Schweinsteiger
and the Fire lead.
[END PLAYBACK]
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Please
give a big round of applause
for Bastian Schweinsteiger.
[APPLAUSE]
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Thank you very much.
STEFAN SCHMAGER:
Welcome to Chicago.
Welcome to Google.
I just said, [SPEAKING GERMAN],,
which is a way
to say, hi, in Bavaria.
Is that right?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
That's true.
It's like I always say
when the people are asking,
what does it mean?
I always say it's like
the Italians say, ciao.
They say ciao for good
morning and ciao for goodbye.
That's the same in Bavarian.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: I'm
from Germany myself,
so I'm very excited to have
Bastian here at Google.
We'll be talking about a
few things around Chicago.
We're going to take a
look back at your career
and the hardships and
bumps along the way
and how we can look forward to
the next Chicago Fire season.
So, in preparation
for this talk,
we looked through your talks
on YouTube and we actually
saw that Ana, your wife--
former French Open champion and
former number one in tennis--
was at Mountain View.
So I wonder, did you guys
talk about her experience
at Google Talks?
And what did she tell you
about Google and the culture?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: Yes,
we were talking about it,
and I remember she was saying
that she was very impressed how
big the complex is over there.
And, also, she had a good chat
over there with the employees--
some of them also
are playing tennis,
so that was also the subject.
And also she was mentioning
that she played bowling
with the CEO, and
that she made--
she never played
before, but she made--
somehow she made a strike
with the first try.
So, yeah, she had a
good time over there.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Very nice.
So Ana is from Serbia, you
are from Germany originally.
It seems that this
city-- this second city
has become somewhat
of a new home.
Would you consider Chicago
as your second home
away from home?
And what makes the
city so great for you?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: Yes,
it's definitely our home
for right now--
where my wife and our
son is-- my family as.
I call it our home.
I must say when
we came over here,
I'd never been to
Chicago before.
I think once with
Manchester United,
we came in, we played a game.
It was kind of a
12-hour stay in Chicago,
but I couldn't see the city.
But when we came over
here, I still remember.
I like the people on
the street like how they
were talking to each other.
They had a kind of a humor
as well which I like a lot.
And, of course, Chicago is a
big sports city as well, which
matches our family quite well.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: I have this
weird memory about soccer
games, and I think you
came here for the preseason
game against Paris.
So you played here
against Ibrahimovic,
whom you played
again last Saturday.
You guys both played
at Manchester United.
Do you guys say hi?
Do you have a short chat or do
you guys meet after the game?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Yes, of course we say hi.
But it's kind of
like in the game--
it's actually funny.
When you play with
a former teammate--
when you play
against each other,
it's tricky because
he's a guy which--
I admire him a lot.
He's one of these
players who think
about a third option when they
play football-- soccer, sorry.
So you usually have some--
they pass the ball from here
to here.
Then you have some
smart players,
they already see
the second station.
And some, they see the third.
And you don't have many of
those players in the world,
and that's why it's very
tricky to play against him.
But I always try to
be smarter than him,
and that's kind of a
challenge on the field.
And it's actually--
I don't know why,
but actually it
was always working quite well,
but, at the end of the day,
he always scored the final goal.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Yeah.
It's amazing to see each other.
You always see each other twice.
If we take a step
back and look at 2015
when you signed with
the Fire, I wonder
after your stops in Munich
and in Manchester United,
what was it that you were
looking for at your new club?
What were factors
that you considered
before joining your next club?
If you can tell us a little
bit about the process
around the time.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: Yes,
I remember that I was always
interested in the MLS.
And then when the possibility
came up to play for Chicago,
I really was
straight interested,
because I also like to
have challenges in life.
And this is a huge opportunity
playing here for Chicago,
and also experience
a new life as well.
It's different than
being in Europe.
And the league, I must
say, it's very interesting.
It's still a young
league, I have to say,
but there's a huge potential
for soccer in America.
And that were kind of
the first thoughts I had.
OK, the Bulls also--
Chicago Bulls played also.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: We'll
touch on American sports
later on as well.
So you've been playing with
the Fire now for two years,
and you said that you want to
help the team become better
and do your part to
elevate the Chicago Fire.
If you look at those
past two seasons,
where do you see the
achievements of your time here?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: I think
especially in the first season,
it went quite well for us.
We learned new things--
tactically things.
I tried to give as my experience
I luckily got in Europe--
tried to help every
guy in our team
to get better every single day.
Sometimes it's just small
things which changes the games.
And I love when we play
as a team on a good level.
And I love to see
ideas on the field
where when you sit-in
the stands you're like,
oh, I couldn't see that coming.
That's kind of my goal
where I try to work on it,
try to help the team
as much as possible.
We had, unfortunately last
year, not our best season.
We had a lot of injured players
from the beginning on which
doesn't make it easier for us.
But now I think we
have a good team.
We are very motivated
for this season.
And I also must say
I love the crowds.
The people in the stadium,
they are very passionate,
but still fair.
And that's really nice.
And, yeah, I just
hope that we're
going to have a healthy
team and also success.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: I
truly do not hope,
but this might be your
last season, possibly.
What do you want achieve this
season with the Chicago Fire?
What's your goal
for this season?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
First of all, I always--
I did the last two
years the same.
I signed a one-year deal.
And, at the end of the
day after the season,
I spoke with my wife, and
then she says, yes or no.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Happy
wife, happy life, right?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: Exactly.
But my goal for this season is--
our goal is to qualify
for the playoffs
and be competitive when we
play against a little bit
better teams.
I still believe we can beat
everyone in this league
if we work on our small details.
We have to improve.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Very cool.
If we take a look at Major
League Soccer in total
as a league, you've
played for the Bundesliga
and for the Premier
League in the UK.
How would you compare
Major League Soccer
with those two top leagues--
both from an aspect
on the field,
but maybe also off the field if
you can draw a few comparisons.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Yes, on the field,
I have to say it's a very
physical league-- the MLS.
It's kind of close, I would
say, to the Premier League
than the Bundesliga.
Some teams are
tactically really good.
They try to do some new
things on the field,
and it's really
interesting to see.
Off the field, I
must say-- which
I love-- is you don't
have hooligans, let's say.
So there is no trouble off
the field, so that's really
a fair audience always when
you play away or at home.
Of course, everyone
wants to win,
but there's nothing happening
around the stadium, which
I love, because you can
go with your family,
with your kids to the
stadium and have a good.
Time and I think
that's very important.
STEFAN SCHMAGER:
Yeah, definitely.
I would like to talk to you
about that picture over there--
we see you with the
World Cup in your hands.
An amazing day of your life, an
amazing day for me in my life
as well.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: I'm
glad I could make you happy.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Unfortunately,
I was here in Chicago.
I couldn't celebrate
back home, but it
was quite all right-- my wife
took really good care of me.
If you think back
of that final day,
you guys won that
semifinal against Brazil--
another day that a lot of
people will never forget.
If you could describe
your thoughts and emotions
around the World Cup Final--
if you can take us back
to that day and kind of
describe your emotions.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
You should not
forget that that was 2014.
But when I started playing
for the national team,
I started 2004.
And actually every
tournament we had--
and we had some in between--
we always played the
semifinal or the final,
but we never lifted
this golden capsule.
And then when we played the
game in the Maracana Stadium
in Rio de Janeiro and
you have the chance
to win the World
Cup as a first team
from Europe in
South America, that
motivates as well a little bit.
But finals are very
difficult to play.
I remember that Argentine--
Argentine?
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Argentina.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: They
had also very good chances,
you know?
And they could score a goal,
and it would be different.
But what I remember quite
well was when we finally
scored the goal, it was
like three minutes before--
it was in extra
time, minute 117.
It was very tough, the
minutes after that goal,
because I remember
when this goal happened
and when they put the
ball back in the kick off,
I had some tears in my eyes.
And you get so emotional.
And there was one
long ball and I
couldn't see the ball clearly,
so I had to do this and this.
So that was not easy.
But it's worked out--
everything, the hard work,
which is where we
started 2004 until 2014.
Sometimes you have to wait,
and there was a kind of moment
there.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: You
mentioned that journey.
The World Cups
before in 2006, you
were eliminated in the
semifinal against Italy.
Four years later in
an amazing World Cup
that the German
national team played,
eliminated yet again in the
semifinal against Spain.
And then once you were so
close to that final World Cup--
the last three minutes--
did you have some sort of doubt
that this may slip away again?
Or are you truly
focused, and do you truly
believe this time
we're going to get it?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: I
always believe in winning.
And I never give up.
And that's my personal
character towards the game.
And even if we would
have been down 1-0, 2-0,
you fight until the end because
in football-- in soccer--
everything is possible
even in 3, 4 minutes.
You can change the game.
And that's my mindset
in every game.
But, of course, I also knew that
maybe this is my last chance
to win the trophy.
And I asked myself,
how many times are you
going to play the
World Cup Final more?
And it's not four or five times.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Can I tell you
a secret around the World Cup
from my perspective?
So your good friend,
Lukas Podolski, he's
been one of my favorite players.
So, since 2006, I had his jersey
for every major tournament--
2006, 2008, all the way to 2014.
And, before we made it--
before you guys made
it to the final.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
It's OK, it's OK.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: I told
my wife and my friends,
I'm going to get the jersey
with the golden patch
of the player that's going
to score the final goal.
It was not you, and,
yet, I bought your jersey
because I think that was
a magnificent performance
in the Final--
a lot of pressure by
the Argentines and just
an amazing performance.
So, there's five Podolski
jerseys and one Schweinsteiger
jersey.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Thank you so much.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: So when we
talk about this achievement--
the World Cup-- there is
another great achievement,
which is the Champions League
with Bayern Munich in 2013.
In my opinion, a similar track--
the team took many attempts
to make it to the Final--
lost the Final in 2010,
yet another Final in 2012,
but then lift the trophy,
ultimately, in 2013
in another legendary stadium
at Wembley in London.
How did your emotions compare
to the World Cup there?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: It
was a little bit different
because I remember
that we played 2012--
the Champions League Final
in our hometown in Munich.
And when you play in
front of your home crowd,
you don't want to
lose the final,
but we did in a very
unlucky way, I must say.
But we lost the final,
so the team was down.
And then to stand up and
straighten the next year
and to lift, then, the trophy,
that meant a lot for me--
but also we as a group,
we stick together.
And I always say that
this kind of defeat
against Chelsea at
home 2012 was kind
of the base for the next steps--
2013 winning of the
Champions League
and also 2014 winning
the World Cup.
But 2013 when we played
the Champions League Final
and we won it, finally
we played the final
against Borussia Dortmund,
which is the biggest
rivalry for us in Germany.
And if we would
have lost this game,
that would be
very, very painful.
And in the first 20 minutes
when we played this game,
there was a lot of
pressure in our game.
And at half time, I asked
Thomas Muller and Phillip Lahm--
I asked them, guys, did you
also feel something the first 20
minutes?
Some heaviness on your back?
And they said, yes, my legs
were completely blocked,
I couldn't move.
It's happening-- these
kind of pressure situations
and we feel that.
Luckily, we could get rid
of it and we won the game.
It's almost the same like in the
World Cup-- in the last minute,
we scored a goal,
which is always better,
because then the other team--
they don't have 30
minutes more to play.
They only have
five, six minutes.
So that was the story about
Champions League Final.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: So you talked
about pressure, especially
with those last finals prior
to the Champions League title.
Your wife Ana at
Mountain View talked
about mental preparedness
and tenants that it helps her
a lot prepare for the games.
I wonder if mental
training has been a success
factor in your career.
Can you tell us a bit about
any type of mental training
that you would do personally,
or maybe even with the team?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
So we had mental coaches
in our clubs, especially
in Munich and also
in the national team.
I know that some of the players
used-- or the staff members are
used to the guys over there.
I, personally, I think that
I kind of know what I want
and I'm kind of strong in a way.
But I also know where
I'm weak, so I can really
adjust to it quite well.
And, of course, sometimes
also talk to the guy,
but not as intensive
maybe than other players,
but we definitely
have the options.
And I think it's good to have,
because you have players--
they need someone to
talk to and maybe you
don't have a family or
environment around you,
which is ideal for you.
And I think nowadays in
sport on this high level,
you need to have also help
a little bit on the side as
well--
even if you are a
tough guy, you know?
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Very good.
I want to touch on one
more thing with regards
to those finals that you won.
Prior to winning
those finals, I think
there was a notion in
the media that, yet
again, that golden generation
is losing another final.
So players like you were
almost proclaimed as failed--
like that they can't make it.
Yet these days, we
have this philosophy
with failure as
postponed success.
And, in soccer, I think it's
a lot about trophies, a lot
about the titles that you win.
Do you think that, in
professional soccer,
there is more of a
movement towards that idea
that we should celebrate failure
a little more, because that's
going to ultimately
lead us to success?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Yes, exactly.
So I remember in
my career, as you
said we lost some
games on a big stage--
finals and semi-finals.
We fell down many times,
but it's very important
to stand up and try to
follow your dreams, you know?
And having your goals in
your mind and being ready--
and sometimes you have
those kind of moments--
not only in sport,
also maybe private--
where it's not easy
to handle your life.
But you only have
one, and you should
try to make the best out of it.
And that's why this was my
mindset is like, you can fall
down, that's not a
problem, but it's
more important to get
up and look forward.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Your
position is midfield.
It's a leading
position on the field,
but I would also
describe you as a leader
off the field for your team.
You've been leader
of Bayern Munich,
at the German national team.
I think that we are a product
of the people that we work with
and that we live with.
You've worked with many players,
many coaches at both Bayern
Munich and the national team.
Who would you say are key
figures that shaped the leader
that you are?
And what are lessons that
you learned from them
along the way?
If you don't want to name
anyone, that's fine too.
I think the lesson piece
is the more important one.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
I mean, I
was lucky to play with big
players during my career.
And I had several guys like
Oliver Kahn guy, for example--
very much believing in his
qualities and fighting,
motivated, extra hours
after the training session.
But I always tried
to kind of get
from every great player or
leader some small things.
I like some things off this
guy, some things off this guy,
and I tried to add
it a little bit.
But being your own person,
that's very important.
And I think that you have--
as a leader, I mean, leader
is a strong word in my eyes.
But you can not
lead a group alone.
You have no chance.
So you need a ton--
more players, 5, 6 players who
play with the same tongue--
who speak with the same tongue.
And that was very
important for me.
And, still, you have
to be a human guy.
Players are not
robots, you know?
They also have a
human side, and you
have to also see that
different players have
a different environment.
They grew up in a different
country, different mentality.
And you all have--
you have to seal all these
facts around the players,
and that's very complex.
But if you want to
achieve something,
you have to be aware of
those kind of things as well.
STEFAN SCHMAGER:
Definitely, yeah.
So if I ask that same question
to one of the young players
on your team--
what is Bastian's
leadership style like--
what would you say?
What are the pillars
of you and the team?
What's important to you
to bring to the team?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
I would love
some young player would sit
here and give you the answer.
I would say that I'm focused.
If I do something, I want
to do it in the right way.
It's kind of a German
way I think as well--
being on time, disciplined,
motivated, focused.
But also having a smile on
your face is very important,
I think.
We have some sessions
where we want to work
and we want to get
better, but then it's
also important to have some
funny moments as well where you
can laugh and have share of
some funny jokes as well.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Yeah, awesome.
So here at Google--
just to divert a little
bit-- we here at Google, we
care about technology,
we love technology.
You played your
first game in 2002.
I looked up the best-selling
or the most-selling device
at that point was
a cell phone that
had a color display
for the first time.
Now in 2019, we
talk to speakers,
we talk to our cell phones.
And I would imagine
that in soccer, there
has been a similar
transformation
around technology.
I wonder how technology,
both during training,
or in preparation for the game,
maybe even after the game,
has made a difference
in your career.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Yes, throughout the years,
it became more and
more important.
And you analyze everything--
how many sprints you make,
and how long you can run,
which distance you
can cover-- which
is, for me, sometimes weird.
Because when a guy covers, let's
say, you run 14 kilometers.
It averages around
11, 12 kilometers--
sorry I don't know
in miles exactly.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: I still
don't get that right either.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: But
maybe of your 14 kilometers,
you run seven wrong.
So using your energy
for the right things,
that is very important.
And I think it's
going to be more
and more important for
the next years as well.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Is
it important for you
to look at those
statistics after a game?
Does it help you improve
for the next game,
or does it give you any
guidance going forward?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Some things
are important-- for example,
all the positioning wise.
Like maybe the goalkeeper cannot
run more than the fullback,
but the fullback can maybe run
more on a high intensity than
a center back.
So there are some stats
where you can kind of compare
to the top teams in,
let's say, Europe,
and I think that's
definitely a good thing.
But sometimes have
lots of games where
you lead in all the stats and
everything, but, at the end,
you lose 1-0, you know?
So it's like both sides of it.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Very cool.
So I could go on and
on with my questions.
I could have a whole day
conversation with you,
but I also want to
make sure that we can--
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: My
wife wouldn't like that.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: I know.
She would give the thumbs down.
I also want to make sure that
the audience is able to address
a few questions to you.
So I can encourage you
to speak to the mic.
The mic is actually over there.
If you want a head
over there and let
us know about your questions.
Chicago Fire was so generous to
provide swag-- a few giveaways.
There's even tickets
involved, so I
would encourage you
to step up to the mic
ask a great question, and
then, afterwards, we're
going to raffle out
prizes so to speak.
So why don't we start with
the gentleman over there?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I'm curious-- when you
came up with Bayern Munich,
I remember you
were a wide player.
And then I think it was
Louis van Gaal who moved
you to play center midfield.
Because I remember watching you
when you were young because you
always used to beat Man United.
It was horrible.
And then you moved to
play center midfield, then
all of a sudden, you were the
most dominant center midfielder
in Europe.
What was that
transition like for you?
And how did you make
that look so easy?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
It's actually
easy to give you the
answer, because I actually
grow as a midfield player.
So at Bayern Munich
in the youth teams--
so when I joined
the club at 14 13,
I started always to play
as a midfield player.
But as soon as I came
up to the second team
and to the first team,
they put me wide.
You know why?
Because in the midfield
players were like huge players.
We had Michael Ballack, and
it's not easy as a young player
to step in that role
immediately where
you have a lot of
responsibility,
because, in soccer,
if this is the field,
a midfield player plays here.
So you're always
close to the action,
and there you have to have
a player who is experienced
who understands the
game quite well.
But I was very lucky
when and I was happy
when Louis van Gaal
changed me into the center
midfield position, because--
I shouldn't compare
it with my life--
my private life-- but I
like to be in control.
So I like to just
dominate the game.
And I don't like when
someone else tells me--
not tells me-- but if the other
opponent dominates the game
and I have to
follow their ideas.
I want to give the ideas
and that's how it is--
at home, I'm different.
AUDIENCE: I read a book
called "The Captain Class,"
and the German team
is featured in it--
especially Philipp
Lahm is a case study.
And they talk specifically
about the controversy
around when he challenged the
board of the team and some
of the surrounding
fallout from that.
Can you talk about maybe
some leadership skills
you learned from Philipp and
maybe around that time period
when I think the
board was like--
I don't know the full
details, but specifically
around some of the
controversy that he stirred.
The book is called
"The Captain Class,"
and they do a case study on
the German team from 2010-2014,
and it's specifically around
the impact that Philipp Lahm.
Can you talk about some
of the leadership skills
you learned from him?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
About his leadership?
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Yeah,
how did you play together
with Philipp Lahm.
What do you--
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
I didn't read the book.
But Philipp Lahm-- it
was actually funny.
The first game I played
with Bayern Munich
was the same time when Philipp
Lahm played his first game.
So it was 2002 in November--
I remember quite well.
And so I-- and also we
know us from the youth,
so I know him as a person,
and and he's a great person.
He was a great football
player as well.
But what maybe is a little bit--
and what matches quite well--
we both kind of like,
in a way, are different.
But together, we were kind
of really very strong.
And we trust each other a lot.
And on the field, we could
play the balls like this,
and so it was not
a problem at all.
And I'm quite sure that
although Philipp will take over
soon a very important position
in the German Football
Association.
AUDIENCE: So one of the things
that's happening at Google
right now is it's review season.
So we're all kind of doing
our self evaluations,
we're evaluating peers.
And I'm curious how you
evaluate your own game.
What are things that you think
you are really strong at,
and what's something that
you might want to work on?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
There are always--
everyday I think that
I can get better.
And when I see something
not happening like I want--
like my brain sometimes
wants something,
but I cannot give it or
bring it on the field,
it makes me angry.
And so, for example--
I mean, now I'm 34 years
old, which is not old.
But, in soccer, you
say it's kind of old.
But I told you before,
it's not about the age,
it's about how many
games you played, right?
And so I try to be
still physically strong.
My body is very
important and I know
exactly what I need to eat,
what I need for the games, what
I need for training
sessions, so that
became through the career
even more important.
And on the field,
I just try to think
about ideas which other teams,
players don't have right now.
So to create something new--
of course, it's a
game, 11 against 11.
It's not one against
11, but I try
to find something where soccer
becomes easier for my team.
So if I can compare, for
example with Pep Guardiola
at Manchester City--
so, of course, Pep Guardiola,
he was a coach at Barcelona,
Bayern Munich, and Manchester
Ciy, which are great clubs.
But everywhere he has success,
and he dominates the games.
And it's not a surprise.
There is a plan
behind their ideas
which are very fascinating
to watch and see.
And it makes me happy to see
some-- when I watch these games
and I see some new movements or
new ideas and new tactical ways
how to play the other team,
that's what I'm looking for.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: It seems
you like the idea of coaching
as well.
Is this something
that you can see
yourself doing in the future?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: I
always say, no, because--
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Your wife.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
No, no, no.
No, no, no, as a coach, you
can get sacked, you know?
As a player, it's impossible.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: One more
question from the audience.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
My wife is OK.
AUDIENCE: Speaking about your
wife, I know you have a--
your son is almost
turning one-year-old.
But let's say he becomes--
imagine the situation.
He's a teenager now,
he's either asked
to play soccer or tennis--
what does he play?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: I mean,
he's born here in Chicago,
so there are other
options as well, right?
Play basketball or for the
Blackhawks, you never know.
So I leave it up to him.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Bastian, it's
an absolute honor meeting you.
I had two favorite players--
one is you and second is Messi.
So welcome--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Sorry, what was the question?
AUDIENCE: I haven't
asked my question yet.
I have two questions.
First is in a football match,
there is a lot of drama,
a lot of things
change very quickly.
One minute you're losing,
then you win-- penalty.
So during a match, how do
you keep your calm and peace
so that you're able
to play effectively?
And my second question is
of the current players,
who is your favorite player?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
The second
was of all the Italian players?
STEFAN SCHMAGER:
The current players.
Current players.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
I mean, there are
many out there,
but when I recently watched
Juventus Turin, I liked--
you probably-- do you
know Leonardo Bonucci?
So I like this kind of player.
Of course Ronaldo and Messi
are amazing how many goals they
score and everything, but I
personally think that also
players like--
I always say Manuel
Neuer and Frank Ribery,
for me, were the best
players I played with.
Different position--
goalkeeper sounds weird
that I would say so, but
the goalkeeper position
is very important and
the center back position
is also important.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: It's surprising
that you mention defenders.
Is this a position you would
have liked to play or could
you see yourself playing
as a central defender?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
I mean, you always
drop-- as a midfield
player, you come
into these kind of positions.
But I think when
you have the ball,
the game starts many
times in the back--
so with the goalkeeper
or with the center back.
And I was asking recently
when a friend of mine--
because we both are watching
the NHL-- and I was asking like,
did ever a player won the
MVP award as a defender
or goalkeeper?
And he said, it never happened.
And I'm questioning, actually,
why it's never happening.
And maybe it will
change one day,
because I think
defenders or goalkeepers
or midfield players, they're
doing also a great job.
It's not always about who
puts the ball in the net.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Yeah.
You mentioned, if I can
interrupt the audience
questions for one moment-- you
mentioned the Chicago sports
teams early on.
You associate Chicago with
Michael Jordan and the Bulls.
You're very active
in the sports scene--
you like to go to see the
Bulls, to see the Blackhawks.
What is your favorite Chicago
team and what do you like--
what do you find
most interesting
about that particular sport?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: So my
favorite team, it's easy to say
is the Fire.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Except
for soccer, yeah.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
But I must say,
I had never been at an
American football game
before in my life, and I really
enjoyed watching the Bears--
especially last season.
But also the other sports is
very interesting to watch.
Ice hockey, for
example, even baseball--
I'd never experienced that.
So my wife is a huge fan of
the Blackhawks-- huge fan.
And I must say I also
like ice hockey a lot.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: So
the Blackhawks it is.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: Yes,
there's only one team, right?
AUDIENCE: Why did
you pick Chicago Fire
and of other teams?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Good question.
Because I actually was in the
kind of a moment in my life
where I tried to
do something else.
And, in Europe, I
always wanted to lift
the Champions League with Bayern
Munich-- that was my dream.
And then when that happened,
I had always Manchester United
in my head, in my
brain to play for.
And that happened as well.
And then I didn't want to play
for a different Cloud in Europe
and I wanted to
move somewhere else.
And I think Chicago
is a great city--
as I mentioned before.
And I had good talks as
well with our President,
Nelson Rodriguez.
And also the owner--
at that time, it was
owner, now we have two.
And that was the reason
why I actually decided
to come over to Chicago.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Chicago Fire
just signed Nicolas Gaitan.
I was wondering if
you had any thoughts
into how he'll fit into what
you guys are trying to do?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Yes, that
was just like 15 minutes ago.
Now one hour and 15 minutes
ago, I got the information.
I know him quite well from the
Benfica Lisbon time over there.
But I never played
against him, but he looks
like a very talented player.
I hope he can help us to
achieve our goals which we have.
And I think he's a
very good player.
AUDIENCE:
[GERMAN SPEECH],, Bastian.
Thank you for making us
world champions, by the way.
I joined that with the speaker.
I moved with my son
recently to Chicago as well,
and I wanted to
ask you privately
what do you enjoy most about
the city outside of football.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
I enjoy the most of--
I walk a lot with my family
around the Lincoln Park area--
the zoo.
My son loves these animals,
and elephants, and stuff.
But I also like a lot that
here is a lake close by
and you can take, for
example, the bikes
and then go along the lake.
That's beautiful-- and
very nice restaurants,
I think, here as well.
And what else do I like?
I love the botanical garden.
Have you been?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We just went last weekend.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Here we go.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: How
about Chicago deep dish?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: I
love the trees over there.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: How about
Chicago deep dish pizza?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: I tried
it once, but it is too much.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: For the
first time when you have it,
you think you can
eat a whole pizza,
but then you
realize really quick
that once slice is enough.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
That's true.
AUDIENCE: I was
actually lucky enough
to see you play against the
United States in Brazil.
During that game, you
actually subbed out,
so I'm not really sure if
you guys were trying or not.
You're one of my
favorite players,
but question about the different
leagues you've been a part of.
Obviously, two of the top
leagues in the world--
MLS is, obviously,
up and coming.
We'll go back to your son.
Let's say he turns into
this amazing soccer player
and he gets to
that age where he's
10, 11, 12-- you can get picked
up by these clubs very early.
Would you encourage
him to stay with MLS
or seek something
across maybe in Europe?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
It's a lot of, if.
For me, first of all,
I think that the MLS--
if the people who
work for the MLS
are making the right decisions,
you can create a huge league.
I know that all the
players in Europe,
they come over to
the United States
and then go for vacations in
a lot of cities over there.
And if you can somehow
use the opportunity
and use the potential
which you have here
to create a great
league, you can
even up with the leagues
in Europe, I think.
And, of course, it takes
some years, for sure.
But there's a
chance if my son is
going to be in MLS or
Europe, I don't know that.
I also don't know if--
maybe he gets the talent--
I'm not a good tennis player.
So if he gets my talent from
playing tennis, it's not good.
Let's see how he ends up.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: I
have another question.
So we talked about--
we touched on the time
after your active career.
You said that coaching
is probably nothing
you would want to pursue.
We also talked about Michael
Jordan, who played basketball
first and then he turned
into a baseball player.
One of the things that
people may not know
is that in your youth, you
were actually also a skier.
You both played
soccer but also ski,
and you pursued both
on a quite serious way.
Can you tell us a bit
about your youth sports--
how you picked
soccer over skiing?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Yeah, it's true.
My father was a skiing racer,
so actually first time I
was in skis, I was like
2 and 1/2 years old.
So I grew up like
close to the mountains,
so that was ideal for me
being outside fresh air.
And in winter I was skiing, in
summer I was playing soccer.
But then there
was a moment I had
to decide between
soccer and skiing,
because I got kind
of the possibility
to move to Bayern
Munich when I was 14.
And then I had to decide.
And it's not easy at
that age to decide,
so it made it kind of simple.
And when you are a
skiing racer, you
have to carry all these skis.
And it's always cold outside.
It's not really enjoyable.
You have to get up early
and all this stuff.
In football, you
just take the cleats
and you play with your friends.
So then I decided
to go for soccer.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Another
question from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for being here today.
I was wondering if there
were any special moments
from your childhood
or your youth
that you remember that were
important moments for you
as a player or as an individual.
And I was also curious if
you had any thoughts on how
the United States might
improve their youth
programs to be a more
competitive nation
in the future.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: Yes,
to your second question,
I think there have to be
a rule where it says, OK,
in every MLS team,
the lineup has
to be players from
the United States--
or in the squad
maybe six players.
And also, for example,
Christian Pulisic,
he plays for Borussia Dortmund.
But the goal should
be for the MLS
to keep the American
players in the league
to make it more popular
for the people over here.
So these kind of rules I
think is possible to do.
But that's how
you would create--
would make the league
higher and also you
would keep the idols for the
kids in the United States
where they can look up to.
And, to the first question--
the first question that--
AUDIENCE: Childhood moments.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Yes, there
was a childhood moment
when I was 15 years old.
I was 15, and I got an offer
from a different club--
and it was not Munich, it
was more north Germany.
And they offered
me a lot of money.
And I could train with
the first team over there.
And I remember that I had--
in that time, my coach was
the son of Franz Beckenbauer.
You all know Franz
Beckenbauer-- he has a son.
And, unfortunately,
he died two years ago,
but I had a good
relationship with him.
And he told me look,
Basti, maybe you
can earn more money
over there and you
train with the first
team over there,
but to go through the
youth team at Bayern Munich
will give you more as a
player and as a person.
And I did that.
So, I am very, very
happy that I had a voice
to talk to in that moment.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Good choice.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Can you please talk--
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Nice jersey, nice jersey.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Oliver Kahn.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Oliver Kahn, here we go.
AUDIENCE: Can you please
talk about how you prepare
on gamedays physically
and, especially,
mentally for big
games-- finals matches--
what's your process before
you walk out onto the field?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Yes before actually it
starts during the
week, but I always
try to eat the right way
two days before the game
so I have a lot of energy.
But then also before I go to
bed a day before the match,
I always try to imagine
how the game could be.
I always ask our kit man
which jerseys are the opponent
playing and which jerseys are
we playing so I can imagine.
We have red and
Borussia Dortmund
plays yellow, for example.
And then I try to think about
all the players on the field--
what's their strengths,
what is their weakness.
What do they like?
Some they don't like
to run with the ball,
some they like to
run with the ball--
so these kind of things--
to be ready for the
moment when it happens--
and, actually, before it
happens that I'm ready.
And I do this all the time.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
STEFAN SCHMAGER:
This is probably
one of the "Talks at
Google" with the most
questions from the audience,
so thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, hi, Basti,
thanks for the opportunity.
I'm also a huge fan of
Bayern Munich and yourself.
I moved to Chicago a year
ago from Germany too,
and I'm interested to know what
do you miss most about Germany?
And also you have
played many games that
went all the way to penalties
and you've shot many penalties,
and I would like
to know what do you
think when you go to the ball?
Are there any thoughts at all,
or are you just cool enough
to go and shoot?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER: Yeah.
Usually the Germans always
win penalty shootouts.
I actually only lost the one--
2012 in the Champions
League Final, unfortunately.
But when you walk from
the halfway line--
from the middle line
towards the ball,
it can happen that
you lose your--
there are too many kids
here, I can't say it.
But you get a little bit
nervous, which is normal,
right?
But it's very
important that you know
what you're going to do
in this kind of moments.
It's very important to
analyze also the goalkeeper
before maybe if you
have the chance.
If you are the first one,
you're a little bit unlucky.
But that always
helped me-- and, yeah,
have the power in your
mind to take that shot
and take the responsibility.
But it's sometimes when you
have 80,000 people around you
and they boo you,
it's not easy--
or it is quiet.
I don't like when it's quiet--
sometimes it's so quiet you
can hear everything dropping.
And the other question was
what I'm going to miss.
There's a special food.
It's called Kaiserschmarrn.
I don't know, you
probably know it, right?
STEFAN SCHMAGER: How
would you describe it?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
It's a pancake--
a thick pancake, but cut it.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: It's a
scrambled pancake in a way,
right?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Yeah, exactly.
And that's what I
loved, actually,
when I was skiing races.
So this kind of food was always
available on the mountains.
AUDIENCE: I know that
from the mountains.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Exactly, exactly.
But I miss that one, yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm nervous coming up
to the mic like a penalty kick.
So this is my husband,
Stephan, and I'm so--
thank you so much for
making this dream--
I'm eight months pregnant,
so I'm also very.
But thank you so
much for making--
making his dream come true.
OK, so I want Stephan--
this is for you to give
Basti a little break
to drink some water.
Stephan, can you
share a little bit
about how this moment came about
and the idea that sparked it?
STEFAN SCHMAGER:
Yeah it's actually--
Google is an amazing place.
You come to Google and
see "Talks at Google"
and how your colleagues
bring in writers and authors.
So it's a very empowering
culture to just give it a shot
and try to reach out
to the Chicago Fire
and see if your favorite player
could come in for a talk.
So, in that sense, I'm
really happy to be here,
to embrace that Google
culture-- and, yeah,
just very happy
to have you here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STEFAN SCHMAGER: I also--
so what she's referring
to is a moment in our life
when you signed with
the Chicago Fire.
It was a week before
my son was born.
A week after my son was born,
I went to your first game
at Toyota Park back then.
And I got him a
Germany jersey hoping
that you could sign it one day.
And I tried really hard.
I set my mind to do it,
and maybe after this talk,
you could give one
more signature.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
No problem, no problem.
For the next one as well, right?
STEFAN SCHMAGER: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: Well, one of the
things you mentioned is at 14,
you already were
going for Bayern.
And what's it like
knowing from a teenager,
having kind of a plan,
and then A, doing it--
getting the Champions
League and then playing
for Manchester United,
and stuff like that--
A, having that course set.
And then, what's it like knowing
that from such a young age
and having that course set?
And then once you
got all this done,
what is it like then having
to face what to do next?
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Yeah, first
of all, I'm very grateful to
have actually the chance to get
picked from out of
1,000 young players
to play for Bayern
Munich when I was 14.
And I remember that--
or I'm playing soccer because
I like the game and I have fun
every single day when I go
right now-- or tomorrow,
I'm going to go to the
training session again,
and I just love the game--
being outside there.
All these things what happens
around, that happens anyway,
so you cannot affect that.
But, of course, when
you lift this trophy
or you lift the
Champions League,
you ask yourself, what's next?
I always tried to find an
answer in kind of challenges.
That's why I also came here.
I want to help the Chicago Fire
to be one of the champions--
to be winners.
And that's what I try to give
to everybody in the club,
and I hope that once
it's going to happen.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: At Google,
we like a challenge,
we are problem solvers.
So if you want to consider this
as your first Google interview,
we can go from here and
schedule another one.
I want to wrap this
up, because we're
getting close to the hour mark.
Bastian, thank you very
much for coming in here.
There will be another game this
Saturday against the Seattle
Sounders.
So, for everyone who--
I was going to switch this,
but it doesn't switch.
Anyways.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
There we go.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: So we
wish you all the best.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Difficult, right?
Just press this button.
STEFAN SCHMAGER: We
wish you all the best
at this coming game
against Seattle Sounders.
Thank you so much for coming
in, answering tough questions,
and spending a
little time with us.
We do also have a
little jersey exchange.
So this is something we
would like to give you
from the Chicago office.
Again, thank you very
much, and this is for you.
BASTIAN SCHWEINSTEIGER:
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]